[Music]
hello and welcome everyone uh good to
see you here there's plenty of room if
you want to come down uh closer um what
what I want to do with uh my colleague
Lori McKenzie today is talk about how we
might Advance women's leadership and um
I thought what I would do to get us
started on that is give you a sense of
where we are in terms of women's
leadership in the United States today so
the slide here um when you take a quick
glance at it what you will notice uh is
that women are underrepresented and
continue to be underrepresented at the
top uh levels of all sectors of our
society so the first two bullet points
show us the dir of women in the
corporate sector if we drop down to the
third bullet point we see that women
make up only 18% of our Congress and
this was after a year which supposedly
just was a watershed of women entering
Congress we're still at only 18% women
University presidencies of our top
research universities only 177% of women
and as low as these numbers are if we
were to drill down and look at women of
color they're considerably lower now
this is actually really quite surprising
in one way and that is it's been over 30
years now since women started
outnumbering men and they're earning a
bachelor's degrees so any of you who are
here from the class of 1980 or 1985 um
you were you know you were in college
about the time when that Tipping Point
happened and if you graduated in say uh
1990 um you were at a period of time uh
here on the farm when people were very
optimist IC about what was going to
happen um with women's leadership matter
of fact if you read books at the time
about gender equality the last chapter
says now with women flooding into
college and getting bachelor's degrees
it's only a matter of time but here we
are 30 years later with these numbers
and we might think about why this is a
problem and maybe that seems obvious to
people who come to a talk on women's
leadership but I want to point out that
in addition to this being a problem for
women there's a societal cost to this we
have to ask ourselves what important
questions and problems aren't being
solved by our companies our governments
and our universities if women's voices
aren't being full more fully included or
to flip that around and be positive
about it think about what we could be
doing in our governments in our
universities and in our companies if we
were more fully drawing on all the
talent that women bring to our society
so that's what I want to talk about with
you today um clearly these numbers are
low for all kinds of reasons I teach a
class one of the Freshman thinking
matters class on this topic and we spend
the entire quarter talking about all
these reasons and how to get Beyond this
today I want to highlight just one
barrier to you that I think is really
important and that is I want to draw out
the way that stereotypes about gender
and work lead to a bias um in how in
terms of how women are um evaluated in
the workplace and so what I'm going to
do is spend some time describing that
problem to you and showing you that it's
more consequential than perhaps we might
think and then I'm going to turn it over
to Lori McKenzie who's going to talk
about some of the tools that we've been
developing to move beyond that bias um
and to create workplaces that more fully
embrace the talent of women in them so I
want to just start off with a research
study um that you may have heard of um
that got a lot of attention when it came
out and really illustrates the kind of
things that I want to share with you
today um and as this picture shows here
the context of this study is orchestras
and the hiring of musicians into
orchestras so in the 70s and 80s in the
United States women made up only 5% of
all Orchestra musicians so this was a
really male type space so we do a lot of
work at the Clayman Institute in Tech
and I think about this and this this was
more male type than Tech is today okay
um and so the orchestras major
orchestras around the country became
concerned that perhaps one of the
reasons there were so few women is that
there was a bias against women in the
audition process and I think about that
you know in the 70s and 80s somebody
making that suggestion I'm sure there
were lots of people that thought that
that seemed ridiculous and doubted that
that was kind of the right answer but to
these orchestra's credit what they did
rather than just debating whether or not
this was the case they decided to do an
experiment and find out and we're always
trying to urge the companies we work do
an experiment let's see so what they did
is they introduced a screen between the
musician um auditioning and the panel of
Judges okay so that the panel of Judges
could no longer tell if the musician was
a male or female now to make it a really
good experiment they found out they also
needed to put carpet down on the floors
because heel clicks we're giving it away
so they want make a really nice
experiment you couldn't tell uh who this
person was and what they found was
rather dramatic that is the introduction
of the screen increased the odds that a
woman would make it past this first
round of auditions by a full
50% so it made a really big difference
okay um if you fast forward to today
women make up 25% of Orchestra musicians
in our top or orchestras 40% overall
still not at parody in orchestras but
this screen really did make a
difference I I lead off with this
example because it illustrates the two
things I want to talk about with you
today one is that stereotypes about
gender affect how women are evaluated
without this screen women were not being
seen as competently as they actually
were and secondly the screen there are
going to be tools that we can develop
that are going to allow us to block the
negative effects of stereotypes on how
women are evaluated now we're not going
to be talking about screens later today
we're going to have to be more creative
than that right but since most of us
couldn't live our work lives behind a
screen and wouldn't want to but we do
have some tools I think can help us get
Beyond um bias so that's where we want
to get to today so I'm going to end up
with this as my conclusion okay and then
we'll we'll work on getting there I want
to first show you how stereotypes limit
women's um leadership okay but all the
way through I want to draw one more
thread and it's not only that these
stereotypes are limiting women's
leadership they're actually interfering
with the goal of having meritocratic
workplaces uh meritocratic workplaces
that are essential to Innovation and
Discovery what I mean by that is this if
we want to be as Innovative as we can be
and if we want to discover the best uh
scientific findings we can find on our
universities and in our companies it's
essential that the best ideas and the
best talents rise to the top and if
that's not happening then we're
interfering with the goal of meritocracy
in addition to limiting women's
leadership so let's talk a little bit
about how this works my job is to sort
of review some of the social science and
share some really cool studies with you
but before doing that I want to talk a
little bit about the the word bias
itself um bias is a word that often
people don't like right it has kind of
this ugly connotation to it as if you're
calling someone sexist or racist or
something but that's not how I'm going
to be using the term here today when I
talk about bias it's simply going to be
an error in decision- making okay so if
we think about the orchestras again I
think we can safely assume that most if
not all of those judges wanted to hire
the best musician possible right they
didn't get out of bed in the morning to
discriminate against women that was
wasn't their goal they wanted to hire
the best musician possible but for
reasons I'm going to explain once they
saw the gender of the musician that
affected how they saw that person's
abilities and skills okay what we're
going to see here today is all of us are
prone to these sorts of biases they're
unconscious biases if you will okay
which is the bad news but the good news
is going to be that there are procedures
in place that we can put in place that
keep us from acting on these biases so I
always describe this as kind of a no
blame High responsibility message so
that's bias how what is that tell us
about how stereotypes work so the key
idea about stereotypes that we want to
talk about today is that stereotypes
function as what we might think of as a
cognitive shortcut and information
processing so let me just talk about the
orchestra One Last Time Imagine That
Orchestra is auditioning like aund
musicians for just two or three openings
and that would not be uncommon at a
major Orchestra if you're one of those
judges that's a lot of information to
take in right a hundred different people
performing you're having to keep all
that information straight in those
information information heavy context we
understandably look for shortcuts to
help us process all that information and
that's not a bad thing I mean we really
none of us today in our jobs as busy as
we are could get anything done at work
if we didn't have some sort of shortcuts
that we took and processing that
information but unfortunately
stereotypes about gender and other
categories of people function as one of
those uh shortcuts and when they do
they're going to create some I think
undesirable outcomes so how does this
work this slide here summarizes 30 years
worth of work on the on stereotypes so
if I'm going through it quickly um you
know 30 years um so what the research
shows us um about stereotypes is that we
instantly within milliseconds sex
categorize any person we interact with
that is we take notice of whether we
think that person is male or female and
we do it in just milliseconds okay I
cannot help doing it in the United
States we do this with race as well so
the things I'm going to talk about with
gender work for race as well in the
United States in other countries they
have different things that they may
instantly categorize people on but in
all known societies sex is one of
those why is that important well once
you put someone in a category or put
anything in a category you unconsciously
or implicitly expect that that person to
be something like that category so
research shows here um with data from
over 30 countries that what happens when
we categorize someone as a man is we're
more quick to associate him with
leadership all the words that have to do
with leadership we can make these quick
unconscious mental associations with
leadership whereas with women instead we
make slower associations with leadership
but quicker associations with things
like being a being a supporter a
follower a contributor but not a leader
what this means is that for Men We tend
to expect men to act more like leaders
psychologists call this agentic to act
active and you know capable of getting
things done and decisive and the way
that leaders act where we expect women
to be warm and communal nice concerned
about others the kind of things we might
expect of someone who is being
supportive and we certainly don't expect
women to be dominant assertive okay we
might expect men to be again at an
unconscious level better at male type
tasks like technology and women better
at female type tasks these stereotypic
um expectations that occur out of
awareness are important because they
frame our shape how we judge people's
performances such the very same
performance looks slightly different to
us if it had been offered by a man
versus a woman and we saw that in the
case of the
orchestras the Bottom bar the problem
with this then when we're thinking about
the world of work and how people might
Advance into leadership is this then
these these quick associations affect
how we evaluate people in the workplace
whether when we're hiring people
thinking about promoting people who to
put on projects it affects the kind of
opportunities we give to people in the
workplace and it affects the amount of
influence people have when someone makes
a suggestion does it sound like like a
good idea okay does it sound like
something worth funding okay I want to
talk to you today about a couple of ways
that that these stereotypes work and
show you some examples and then we'll
turn to the important ending point that
we want to get to today how do we block
these effects okay so the first the
first way that stereotypes work is they
shift the standard that we use to judge
people so it turns out our standards
shift around a little bit depending on
if we're evaluating a man versus a woman
or if we're evaluating in the case of
race someone who's white versus a person
of color if you think about why this
would be I'll use gender as an example
here um if a woman performs well and
especially if it was in a male typed
domain this runs counter to those quick
associations we have so one thing that
we tend to do is to more carefully
scrutinize her performance and we do
this even if in a situation where we're
in awe of her so I've been talking a lot
about um Mary Bara the CEO of uh of of
General Motors Stanford Alum um when
General Motors announced the new CEO and
it was a woman I don't know about you
but this caught me by surprise right I
it's this is the you know automobile
industry who would have seen this coming
so I was kind of you know so I found
myself reading and reading about you
know why it is how how did she get to
this point in her life if General Motors
had announced the new CEO was a man I
probably would have just like turned the
page and read something else it wouldn't
have been news to me but that extra
scrutiny can can under certain
circumstances open the door to bias so
let me give you a couple of examples of
this I want to start with an example
that comes from the field of psychology
um and this is an experiment where what
the authors of the study did is they
created a resume for a person who had
just gotten his or her PhD in Psychology
so it had some Publications on it
teaching experience stuff like that and
they sent it out to psychology faculty
all over the United States and they said
evaluate this person and importantly
tell us whether or not you think this
person would be worthy of a tenure track
position in your
department the experiment was this half
the people out there received the resume
with a man's name on it and the other
half of the psychology faculty doing the
rating received the very same resume
except with a woman's name on it so this
is a really great way to see whether
gender matters right the resume is the
same the only thing's different is the
name what they found was again rather
striking 79% of the people who got a
resume with a man's name on it said he
would be worthy of hire compared to only
49% of people who got the same resume
except with a woman's name on it and in
case you're wondering it did not matter
whether the person doing the rating was
male or female okay male and female
Raiders exhibited the same level of bias
we find this constantly in these studies
and sometimes this disappoints people
they want women to like be better
Raiders than than men um but the the
issue is these are stereotypes that
we're all kind of commonly aware of and
they're affecting our judgments at an
unconscious level now in a second phase
of the study what they did is they had
people evaluate these same resumés
except now these people are more
experienced okay so now we're talking
more about people you might move want to
move into leadership so they have more
grants more Publications and the like
and what they found with these more
advanced candidates is that people wrote
four times more doubt raising statements
on the rating forms for women compared
to men so I would need to see evidence
she'd gotten these grants on her own for
example notice that extra scrutiny
that's going on there or it would be
impossible to make such a judgment
without seeing teaching evaluations now
if you think about it a teaching
evaluation and wanting to see people's
teaching evaluations before you hire
them as a professor that's a very
legitimate thing right I would hope that
we would want to see that but the
criteria is being enforced more rigidly
for women than it is for
men now I want to just um switch gears
just slightly and show you another very
similar study that was done in the
context of race we work a lot at the
Clayman Institute for gender research on
gender issues but a lot of the things
that we're talking about work similarly
for race so if we're trying to create
create more inclusive workplaces a lot
of the take-home mess messages here will
be the same so this study was done in
2014 and what the authors of the study
did is they created a legal memo that
was ostensively written by a third-year
law associate named Thomas Meyer who had
gotten his law degree at NYU and in the
memo what they did is they embedded it
with certain numbers of Errors so there
were some spelling errors there were
some factual errors and there were some
analytical errors and then they send it
out to law partners and asked the law
partner to rate the memo and give the
person some feedback on how they were
doing very and so the experiment very
similar to the last one the only
difference was that half the people were
told that Thomas Meyer was White and the
other half were told that he was black
but the Memo's the same and what we find
is this there were three times more
edits and comments written on the black
Thomas Meyers memo that compared to the
White Version okay again the same memo
and they were twice as likely to find
mistakes so notice again that extra
scrutiny that's going on for the person
for whom whom people probably didn't
expect they were going to be as good to
start with they were doing what they
were supposed to here right they were
supposed to be finding the mistakes but
the person over here was getting kind of
a leniency bias and this is what we see
a lot in these studies is this extra
scrutiny of women and people of color
with criteria that's very legitimate
being applied more rigidly to them this
affected how people rated the memos not
surprisingly the rating was considerably
and significantly higher for white
Thomas Meyer than for black Thomas Meyer
and it also affected their qualitative
judge ments so the white Thomas Meyer is
generally a good writer um has potential
black Thomas Meer needs lots of work
can't believe he went to myyu so these
sort of drastic differences in how
they're talking about this performance
so you can imagine how this would affect
a advancement into leadership going
forward one final example I want to give
in this area comes from some work that I
that I've done um and you know when we
think about the experiences women have
in the workplace the experiences women
have in the workplace are not just
because they're a woman because no one's
just a woman right you're a woman you're
also you have a race you have a sexual
orientation you might have children you
might not you might be disabled and all
these other things combine to affect the
judgments um that we make of people so
I've done some work um um looking at how
being a mother might lead to
disadvantages in the workplace there's
some um literature out there on wage
gaps that show that mothers experience a
five to 7% wage penalty per child
compared to childless women okay and
this is if you're car comparing men and
women and I mean childless women and uh
and mothers who are in the same kind of
jobs so I was concerned whether this
kind of biasing process might be
affecting mothers as well so what we did
is an experiment where we had people
evaluate either two women or two men one
of whom was a parent and one of whom was
childless um so down in the resume of
one of the two members of the pair you
learned that the person was an officer
in an elementary parent teacher
Association okay so that's a subtle
indicator that someone might be a
parent I mean you don't have to be a
parent to be an officer in an elementary
school parent teacher Association but I
don't really think ever in the history
of the PTA has there been an officer who
was not a parent so this very
effectively conveyed parent status now
before starting the study what we did is
we pre-tested all of our materials to be
sure we had two people who when we
didn't know their their gender and we
didn't know their parental status were
judged to be equally qualified so just
based on their resumés and performance
evaluation so there was no difference
put names on the files um mark one is a
parent what happens all of a sudden the
child is the mother is seen as
significantly less hirable so they would
they said they would recommend 84% um
said they would recommend the person who
was childless compared to only 47% for
the mother further if they were going to
hire the person they were going to pay
her significantly and substantially less
okay so we see some evidence of a bias
for fathers no such bias um in fact
fathers fathers are actually preferred
compared to childless women and if
they're going to be higher they're going
to be paid uh significantly um more than
childless men so we see how parenthood's
working differently for moms than for
dads we drilled down one more um to try
to one more layer to try to figure out
what's going on here and what we found
is that people were stereotyping the
mothers as being less competent at their
jobs and less committed to them compared
to the fathers who were seen as more
competent and more committed to their
jobs now when I got these results you
know I sort of suspected that I would
get this difference in commitment
because there's pretty strong
stereotypes out there that mothers
aren't as committed to their jobs it's
it turns out that there's not a lot of
data to support that but there is these
stereotypes but the competence think
kind of weird why would someone all of a
sudden be like less have less brain
power after they had a child um so I
went to talk to one of my friends debor
R in the law school and I was telling
her about this and she had just done
some work where she was interviewing um
Law Associates coming back from
maternity leave and these Law Associates
were complaining that when they came
back from maternity leave they weren't
getting as interesting of work anymore
they were getting like paralal level
work and not the kind of work they had
been getting before and she told me that
one of the people that She interviewed
told her boss I had a baby not a
labotomy to kind of drive home that
point so what we've seen here is that
stereotypes can can lead to this extra
scrutiny right we've seen it now for
women we saw it for African-American men
we've seen it from others we might ask
whether or not um why whether or not
women might be able to overcome doubts
about their competence and get beyond
the effects of stereotypes I mean what
stereotypes are doing is causing us to
see people is less competent than they
are could we get past this barrier by
asking women to self-promote you know
toot your own horn make sure people are
listening to you could that help get
Beyond this barrier well Lori Redmond
has done some interesting work in this
regard she's done a series of
experiments where um part people are
evaluating people who are interviewing
for a job so if you were in this study
you'd be watching somebody who was
interviewing for a job and then you
would give feedback to that person half
the people are interviewing women half
the people I mean half the people are
rating women half the people are rating
men and half the people are rating
people who are modest so in the
interview they talk about what they've
done but maybe they give credit to their
teammates or I got lucky or something
like that the other half are evaluating
people who are self-promoting so you can
imagine this person I drove sales I did
this a lot of the language of I so the
question is does this work we often tell
this to women you know you need to you
need to self-promote if you don't toot
your own horn no one else will I don't
know if you've heard that saying it's
interesting that's a very Western saying
um and and uh in certain Eastern
countries there's the corollary
statement that says the loudest duck
gets shot okay that means something
different than you know toot your own
horn but in at least the United States
and many Western countries this is what
we tell people does it work well it
turns out for both men and women yes
people who self-promoted both men and
women were judged to be more competent
than their more modest counterparts so
it raised people's sense of uh perceived
competence that's a good thing but for
women it also decreased their life
ability so these more self-promoting
women were seen as more competent but
people didn't like them okay what's
going on there well our stereotypes
about women are that they should be
modest not dominant or assertive so this
was a violation of a stereotype and was
creating what Scholars call this
likeability penalty men occur no such
penalty okay they were just the more
self-promoting man was just as like is
his more modest counterpart now you
might think so what you know if I'm
interviewing for a job I want to be seen
as competent that's more important than
likable right that if that is the
trade-off I would rather be competent
than likable right um as my colleague
Maggie Neil here in The Graduate School
of Business likes to say if you want to
be liked get a dog you know I mean this
is this is work you know but it does it
turns out it matters okay um for the man
who was more self-promoting he was more
likely to be recommended for higher
people liked him and they thought he was
competent that's a win-win but for the
woman who was more self-promoting she
was no more likely to be hired people
didn't want to hire her because they
didn't like her and they didn't want to
hire her more modest counterpart because
because they didn't think she was very
competent okay so this is a bad tradeoff
right um this likeability penalty is
especially important for women as they
move into leadership roles because
leadership roles are really about sort
of enacting more um agentic
self-promoting Behavior to some extent
okay so if we're trying to advance
women's leadership we've got to get past
this liability penalty I want to show
you one more example of the way
stereotypes work and then we'll turn to
Solutions and that is stereotypes also
can shift around the very criteria we
use when making decisions about people
so I'll just show you uh this particular
study um this study the context is
people are being um considered to be
hired as a police chief so police chief
um is a leadership position you know
head of the police department um it's
also a kind of male typed job um and so
what the authors of this study did is
they created resumés for two candidates
for police chief okay and they created
them to be equivalently qualified except
one person had more education that was
relevant to being a police chief and the
other person had more experience so
these are kind of two criteria you might
care about and one person's strong on
one and one's strong on the other and
that's often when we're making hiring
and promotion decisions that's how it is
somebody seems better on this hand but
the other one's better on that hand so
in the first phase of the experiment
they have no names on the file we don't
know who's male or female or anything
else about them except what they've done
on the job and what we find is that
people overwhelmingly prefer the person
on the left and when they're asked to
justify their choice they say he has
more education or this person has more
education so all this is telling us is
in this population people are waiting
the criteria of Education more heavily
than they're waiting experience okay so
that's all we've learned in the next
wave of the experiment what they do is
they put names on the files they get a
different set of Raiders to rate the two
applicants okay and now we have the
man's name on the file that has more
education and the woman's name on the
file that has more experience so what we
would expect here is that people you
know based on what we learned in the
first condition of the experiment we
would expect that people would prefer
the man because he has more education
and education seems to be the criteria
that people were waiting more heavily
and that's what we find okay so people
preferred the man and they asked to
justify their choice they said he has
more
education what gets interesting is this
third condition okay now we grab a
different set of Raiders okay we give
them the same two resumés we just swap
the names around so now the woman's name
is on the file with more education and
I've seen a couple people in the room
laughing they see where this is going
right um so what we if if education is
the criter that carries the day if it's
where we're waiting things more heavily
we would expect that the woman would be
chosen for the job and all the people
shaking their heads are betting no
wouldn't make any sense if this was in
my slideshow if that was what happened
um and instead what happens is they
still prefer the man and when they
justify their choice it's because he has
more experience so notice what's
happened is the criteria has shifted
from education um to experience to
justify probably what what was people's
gut hunch this person was more right for
the
job okay so we we've seen a lot of
depressing stuff here on reunion weekend
back on a sunny day on the farm right
we've seen how stereotypes shift our
criteria around our standards around the
likeability py all this let's end on a
positive note by talking how we can get
Beyond these effects okay and what I
want to suggest is that our Solutions
share one thing in common and that is
they have to break the tendency to use
stereotypes as a shortcut that's what
got us into trouble to begin with good
well-intentioned people who are very
busy trying to process all the
information on their job in implicit or
unconscious way stereotypes are
affecting those judgments so how can we
get beyond that we've been doing a lot
of work at the Clayman Institute um on a
project that we colloquially like to
call C bias block bias I'm working with
companies in the Silicon Valley and
Beyond to First help people see bias in
their workplace because these biases are
unconscious or implicit they're often
hard to see so what can we do to help
people see bias and then what kind of
tools can we devise to block the use of
that bias well on the seeing bias front
one thing that really helps is teaching
people about how stereotypes work once
people understand how stereotypes work
they tend to be more careful and
thoughtful in their own decision making
so this is a good first step however
it's not going to take us all that far
and I think we all know why that is any
kind of education or training that
you've ever had even if it was really
impactful right it impacts you a lot
today and maybe next week and the week
after it's like a New Year's resolution
right we're good in January we're still
okay in February March comes it's gone
um these things wear off and I think
about this on reunion weekend every time
you know I'm you know on campus I I
think about like what if I could
remember all the stuff I had learned at
Stanford I hadn't forgotten any of it
how smart I would seem these things we
away so we're going to have to do
something more than just educate people
we're going to have to change the way we
work so what I want to end with and then
I'm going to turn it over to Lori I want
to talk just a little bit about what
organizations can do to get Beyond bias
and then Lori is going to talk about
what we as individuals can do okay and
that's how we'll end up today so in
terms of what organizations can do
there's really two broad buckets of
things that we like to work on um the
first is that we can change the
stereotypes about leadership or more
generally change the stereotypes in our
organization about what success is like
um so in the case of leadership even
though we know that leaders embody a
diverse array of traits people's
stereotypes about leaders are very
narrow they're the Steve Jobs of the
world these they these these the born
Geniuses that you know Drive change even
if they have to step on people it
doesn't matter we have this of
stereotypes about leadership and that
causes women to not see themselves as
being as leader-like and it causes
people judging women's performances to
not see them as being that as
leader-like the the association of women
in science is an interesting example
here this is a group of uh a women's
groups that are across the 22
professional science Societies in um in
in our country so like the American
Chemical Society for example and what
they noticed is that women were winning
very few career achievement awards the
awards that signal that you're just at
the Pinnacle of your career very few
women were getting them even though the
pipeline of women was getting Fuller and
Fuller so what they did in some of the
societies was an experiment where they
changed the words they used in the call
for nominations and rather than
describing the person as just being a
genius and pathbreaking they said please
nominate people who've had care
considerable achievements in their
career and that makes sense because
these were career achievement awards
right but that language changing that
language caused many more women to apply
for the awards and for women to start
winning the awards at a higher rate so
broadening stereotypes about leadership
and success could be useful secondly we
need to change our evaluation processes
when we're hiring and promoting people
to block the effects of stereotypes and
I want to give you just a few quick
examples here one is that we need to
develop clear criteria before people
make evaluations that police chief study
I told you about there was one final
condition and in this condition what
they said to the new set of Raiders is
this before we show you any applicants
write down what really matters to you
and guess what people wrote down
education and then when they saw women
who had more education they chose them
for the job there's about two decades
with a research now that shows the
clearer the criteria the more likely we
are to hire and promote women and people
of color when you have clear criteria
you don't need the shortcuts that
stereotypes provide secondly we need to
ensure that the criteria is evenly
applied okay to all people so think back
to the psychology study I would need to
see evidence of her teaching evaluations
if you're in a meeting and someone says
something like that what somebody in the
room needs to be doing and we call this
person a criteria monitor this person
needs to be saying if we're going to
consider teaching evaluations why don't
we go back and apply that to everyone
okay that can be very helpful third we
need to increase accountabil ility and
transparency okay with accountability
people are asked to justify their
choices and when people have to justify
who they're hiring or who they're
promoting they tend to make more
thoughtful decisions they you know if
I'm gonna have to explain to you why I
preferred someone I can't just say it
was a hunch and I have to sort of think
through what the criteria are and how
the person mapped on to those
transparency posting numbers keeping
track of how you're doing um in terms of
hiring women and other diverse groups we
do this at Stanford every year in the
Spring quarter one of the vice provos
comes to the faculty Senate and gives a
report that we call gains and losses and
basically what we're doing here is we're
looking at how have we done in gaining
women faculty and gaining faculty of
color relative to losing those groups of
people the goal is that we want our
faculty to look more like our student
body and by being uh transparent and
collecting data on that we keep
ourselves focused on that goal and
managing towards that goal and then
finally question don't assume Merit
ocracy we work in a place especially
here in the Silicon Valley where people
tend to think that their organization is
meritocratic they're quantitative data
oriented people and they think they are
meritocratic but Recent research has
shown that organizations who think they
are meritocratic are actually more prone
to biases than organizations that know
that they still have work to do okay so
if meritocracy is your goal but if you
treat it like a reality it undermines
the goal and it makes sense when you
think about it right if you think you
already are meritocratic there's no
biases in your organization you don't
have a problem you're probably not going
to be that conscious of trying to solve
the problem so questioning meritocracy
and constantly asking um and and wanting
evidence about how we're doing in terms
of being fair and hiring and promotion
is actually really quite important now I
know that not everyone here um is in
running an organization where these
points are that relevant so what I want
to do is turn it over to Lori who is now
going to talk a little bit with you
about what individuals can do um
tomorrow to start driving us towards a
world that is more
meritocratic I think you've seen from
the research that we're in a society
with these shared cultural beliefs it's
something we all share so sometimes
people say that's the point in the
presentation where your kind of
enthusiasm goes down it's my job to
bring you back up to that we can do
something together I'm going to actually
ask you to see the Unseen and when I
think about that I think about these
puzzles how many of you can see the face
of an old lady in in this puzzle okay
and how many of you can see the face of
a young lady in this puzzle oh great
it's funny when I do this with a lot of
tech companies the young face gets a lot
of hands and the old face doesn't get as
many so I think we have some age bias
going on in Silicon Valley so the
interesting thing is it can actually
take you some time to be able to see
both these faces at the one reunion
weekend this young boy had never seen it
he got in about a minute and sometimes I
find the older I get the harder it is
for me to see both sides of an equation
the good news is though that what we've
learned is once your brain identifies
both it cannot unse seee them again so I
hadn't seen this puzzle for about five
years and when it they showed it to me
again I'm like oh yeah there's an old
face and a young face so our goal with
all of our bias training is to ensure
that we present you a way to see bias in
a way you can't and see it again and
then to have the tools to be able to
block
bias we're going to start with an
experiment in language so yes you get to
do this classes without quizzes I'm not
going to quiz you but we're going to do
some experiments together we're going to
do an experiment in language because
language is the most common way that we
maintain and replicate cultures in our
families in our communities and in our
workplaces I'm going to have you do an
experiment so you must you should have
gotten a piece of paper when you came in
you don't have to use it I find also
people a lot of people like to use their
devices so um there's a piece of paper
we have some pens as
well and all I want you to do is
describe a top performer so if you think
of that in a workplace context it might
be a team you're on and there's one
person you can always count on it could
be in your community where I live
there's this one family they always host
all the block parties so I would count
on her all the time to host these that
family to host the block parties it
could be in your family
so my job in my family is to plan all
our vacations and in that context I
would be called the top performer of my
family's vacation planning so whatever
context you have think of a top
performer and on that sheet of paper
just take a minute to describe in a few
words the behaviors and attributes of
that top
performer doesn't have to be a complete
sentence or a resume just a few words to
describe a top performer whether it's at
home at work or in your family and thank
you for passing out the
pens oh pen
here you thought this was classes
without
quizzes so think of that person in
particular not a g enal top performer
and a few words to describe the
behaviors and attributes of that top
performer okay does everyone have at
least one word down for their top
performer great now here's the thought
experiment and I'm going to show you two
descriptions and they're written
differently intentionally so this is
never going to be how it would show up
in life but just come along with me on
this journey of this thought experiment
imagine that I've taken that top
performer away
and I'm going to show you the
description of two different people and
I'm going to have you pick the person to
replace your top performer so for
example in my family if I no longer were
planning our vacations I'd say to my
family pick the person to plan the top
vacation right so in the workplace it
could be on your team imagine that
person got recruited or promoted out of
your team and you're looking for a
replacement and I'm going to ask you to
pick description a or description B to
replace your top
performer okay and yes they're written
very differently this is just an
experiment now how many would replace
their top performer with description
a okay I would say it's 15% 20% how
about with description B okay maybe
75% right interesting did you notice
I've been priming you all the time by
saying top performer top performer top
performer notice how language has
created an association of a type of
person and and even when you're asked to
pick a substitution for that person with
just four words or able to do it 80% of
us pick description a if I had said
instead imagine the person you can on
the most to support you in your times of
need even if that's the same person you
might have picked a different
description notice how language is
priming us to make associations as
Shelly said and make decisions off just
a few words now why does this matter
researches at Rice University the went
through 400 letters of recommendation
for the position of medical Chief
imagine medical Chief is the person
who's making life or death situations
for a lot of
people and the researchers noticed that
the more communal language that was used
which is description a the less likely a
candidate was to be put forward so when
I think of communal language I think of
it as the language of we of community
and of
collaboration the more agentic language
that was used so when I think of agentic
language I think of agency or the
language of I I am independently driving
to an
outcome the more a a communal language
that was used the less likely that
candidate was to be put forward now
thinking about us doing a presentation
on women's leadership guess what kind of
person is more likely to be described
with communal language women with the
exact same qualifications so the letter
writers are the people who most want
this person to be considered as the top
candidate and simply by using language
that was more communal in nature their
advocacy was less effective why does
this matter so as Shelly said we're
using stereotypes as these cognitive
shortcuts now are there any native
Russian speakers in the
room no okay so apparently in Russian
there's two words for the color blue so
if I showed you something that was blue
and you're a native Russian speaker your
brain would take a slight longer bit to
sort it because you're sorting is that
blue or is that light blue or dark blue
but in English there's only one color so
if I show you something that's blue
you'll sort it more quickly so the more
binary something is the faster our brain
can make these decisions the more Shades
of Gray there are the slower those
cognitive processes are now part of what
starts to happen is you assume in this
binary world that the other doesn't
exist so if I assume that you're very
communal you're very good team player I
might wonder are you also willing to
drive a decision home and if you're more
agentic you're more driven I might
wonder are you also able to be a great
team player now here's the thing about
leadership when we're asked quickly to
decide about someone's leadership we're
more likely to associate leader with
agentic qualities
even though we want a spectrum of
qualities with leadership when we're
making those cognitive shortcuts we're
much more likely to rely on agentic
terms in making those decisions so you
can see that the very use of language as
an automatic function seeing somebody
who's equally qualified but
foregrounding different
qualifications has them show up
differently when being evaluated for a
leadership
position here's the kind of list there
is that list is also on the back of your
handout for you to use often times my
friends will use this so I just wrote um
a letter recommendation for somebody to
get into college and submitted it to the
Common App and I was very conscious of
the kind of language that I was using in
my letter of recommendation often people
will go looked at their LinkedIn
profiles to see how they've described
their own
accomplishments or they might even look
at their LinkedIn endorsements how have
you in a quick you know know endorsement
of someone used language that might not
have them seem as much of a leader I
have a friend who's um
um a a project manager and she's really
effective and she said everyone just
says I'm friendly and no one says I'm
strategic and I said oh she's also Asian
Asians are perceived to be very good at
tasks so when someone sees her they see
the task orientation she has and they
forget that she was very strategic in
how she planned the events
so after she did the presentation the
next time she asked for a LinkedIn
endorsement she primed that person to
talk about certain qualifications she
had so she would finally have a LinkedIn
endorsement that didn't say she's really
good at managing tasks
um I just want to give you an example so
at our Institute we're often given
informal recommendations so when we're
hiring someone for a job someone will
send a note to someone to send to us so
that they know that their person should
be highly considered for a job so I want
to show you um a little bit of that I'm
going to diagnose the language that was
used this is also a warning never send
me a letter of recommendation if you
don't want it to show up on screen I'm
just kidding so this is for someone who
worked on Capitol Hill it was for us one
of our most senior positions it's for
the position of marketing director and
this person went to one person to
another person to really get me this
because as you see this was high high
praise for this candidate I'm going to
to the language a little bit notice the
words in Black these are her strongest
endorsements of the candidate notice
it's very vague scholar of what
professional who led what accomplishment
so even this was High Praise I actually
don't know much more about this
candidate than I would from a letter
that didn't say much about her another
thing we know about women is they're
more often described through their
personality ities then with their
accomplishments and when their
accomplishments are described they're
often much more vague and they don't
have business outcomes attached to it so
this is another Trend we know from our
research notice that word actually she
and I actually worked together our
research also shows that there are many
more doubt raising statements in women's
performance evaluations she managed to
lead a good team not she led a good
team in the end she managed to deliver
the project on time why do we need to
say in the end in the end implies there
wasn't always going to be on track right
so this kind of doubt raising statement
we also find as much more common in our
evaluations of women and lastly look at
the traits of this person so this person
I later Learned was a highly rated
scholar who had used her scholarship to
advance an agenda that went to to
Congress none of that was mentioned here
all I got was that she was passionate
committed and determined now I don't
know about you but as a woman I'm often
called Tire tirelessly dedicated I don't
know if that's code for something but
when we look through the performance
evaluations of women they're also more
commonly coded as tirelessly dedicated
and one of the things I always think is
so funny is we're in this culture of
Genius right we want the next Steve Jobs
we want the next startup in this culture
of Genius it kind of is supposed to just
come to you and the rest of us are
working tirelessly and dedicated right
so This research we did as I talked
about was performance evaluations which
we redacted and took the gender out and
then we evaluated them for the way
language was used the reason we do this
at the climate Institute is that we want
to provide practical solutions for
companies to then block bias in their
processes so if I broadly say to you
don't make vague praise that's one thing
but if I said here's exactly the way
vague praise works in your company
you'll more able to train people not to
use praise in that way so this was
posted recently in the Wall Street
Journal it's part of a two-year research
project we've been working on with some
sites across the country to understand
exactly how does bias play out you can
see some of the things we talked about
women are given much less
feedback and when they are given
feedback it's not very specific so I
thought this was fake but it's an actual
citation when woman was told to show it
more at work that was her feedback she
got I don't really know for why what
would the outcome be and what would that
provide for me to produce more results
the man on the other hand was told
combine technology a with technology B
and together that will help you launch
this new platform you can hear that that
vagueness doesn't really help me much on
my job so women are getting less
developmental feedback they're getting a
lot more criticism of their
communication style do you remember Shel
talked about the liability
penalty the way the liability penalty
will show up at work is you'll either be
called not clear and concise at entry
level or offputting at the senior level
so we notice the way communication shows
up as a likability penalty in
performance reviews we're really excited
that we're launching this new research
in a three-part launch and more excited
that we'll be launching This research as
part of a national Summit in March
2017 thanks to the generous support of
GSB Alum Bruce Golden and his wife
Michel Michelle Mercer who was an
undergrad and law degree will'll be
launching this as a national
conversation to try to see and block
bias in all of our
workplaces so this is the end of our
presentation because we promis to allow
some time for questions so sh do you
want to come back on stage oh oh one
action you can do tomorrow shelle said I
would give you solutions that you could
do tomorrow when one thing you can do
endorse a woman do you remember when
Shelley said that if you toot your own
horn people might not like you an
experiment was done where a professor
said in one experiment here's my ta and
just mentioned her name in another
condition he tooted her horn for her and
said how amazing she was what
Publications she had why they should
listen to her in the condition where the
professor tooted the horn for her her
ratings went up so even if women might
have to navigate the likability penalty
around tooting their own horn you can
toot their horn for her so always
introducing a woman making sure you
vouch for her competence is one way that
you can work towards her being
recognized as an expert as a leader
another thing you can do is just block
the automatic use of language don't
write a letter of recommendation without
thinking what am I trying to say about
somebody um you could also I notice this
with my kids too what I'm criticizing
about them by gender and trying to make
sure I do that equally for them and
lastly you can update your resume or
LinkedIn profile or have someone you
know update their resume or LinkedIn
profile to be reflective of their true
accomplishments in ways that will help
them attain everything that they want in
leadership so with that we'll see if if
you have any questions there's a couple
of microphones in the room so if you
have a question if you could go to the
microphone um otherwise we have to
repeat it and we may botch it
so yes yeah thanks so much this is uh
really helpful and and for me I I work
at the World Bank in Washington and
we're actually going through an edge
survey right now as part of the uh the
gender strategy for the organization and
I I hope that they make um the comments
public for at least the staff I mean
because they had did when it was both
men and women commenting and this is
something that's gone out just to the
women so um but a lot of this resonates
very much my question is I'm the mother
of three teenage girls and my middle
daughter is you know I think has a lot
of very intrinsic leadership qualities
but those things can sometimes be make
it difficult she's you know in the 10th
grade and um I'm looking for you know
different kinds of programs or ways to
support her I mean in all three of them
but especially her that she's got that
um we were in the power I was in the
power one earlier you know the little
girl that was many any of you were in
that one but they were talking about
girls versus boys she's got some of
those characteristics that are um you
know sometimes off-putting I think to
both girls and boys and I want to help
to you know give her the tools she needs
as well as my other girls I just
wondered if you had anything for the
kind of that next Generation yeah I
should say that that's a it's a a very
it's a very common finding with uh with
young with young girls that are
exhibiting um leadership Behavior to be
called you know bossy for example which
is a derogatory term and I think serves
to dampen their ambition and I it's
something I think we just absolutely
don't want to do so the question is what
can we do then to um provide a good
space for them to develop those skills
and recognize those skills I mean I
think one um you know as a uh you know
to Lor's point about endorsing the
competence of other people to sort of to
to very clearly um try to correct some
of those things amongst the the people
who might be critical of her so I think
it's you know important when a a girl is
exhibiting leadership skills and and
there's negative attention drawn to that
for somebody to be able to say about her
you know I think she actually could be
running her class or something like that
she Cheryl Samberg loves to say say she
has executive presence instead of she's
bossy but to reframe what it means
um to be a leader for a young girl I
think is actually really important and
then there's there's all kinds of
starting to emerge new kinds of
workshops and things that you can send
her to where she'll be around other
people peers that are more like her
which helps validate that so we've been
we have a program we call seeds of
change that is a middle school high
school girls kind of a leadership
program and not only does it teach
skills but it puts them in contact with
other girls who value those same skills
and that's very important is to have
that peer group it's a great question
yeah we also have some free videos
online under voice and influence so
they're professors like Maggie Neil from
the business school and Deb grunfeld
here as well and I have a girl who's in
seventh grade and I've watched them with
her and talked about them and one of the
things we know about young girls is you
can't always figure out what their peers
will say and give them ideas about how
you can frame opportunities for them but
another thing to think about is what's
their why they're doing things being in
touch with a leadership purpose or a
vision purpose or something like that
can help you figure out oh maybe it's
worth having someone call me bossy
because I'm gonna go change the world so
sometimes our work of seeds of change
part of what's in there is find helping
young girls find the why and then going
back to that why when they do face some
of that push back externally okay so
we'll go here and then over here next go
ahead okay um as of the feedback loops
and the degree to which women receive
positive feedback relative to men how
much is any Workman done on on looking
at the at the sexuality aspect positive
input is the language of intimacy at
some level and some men feel far more
uncomfortable with that or knowing how
to rephrase or reframe what they want to
say so that it doesn't take on context
yeah or that doesn't bother their own
subconscious feelings right has there
been any work on this yeah you know
there's so there uh there there is some
work that shows that that is one of the
barriers that some men will describe and
say mentoring women for example I mean
you know how is it going to look I you
know you know hanging out with this
woman in a bar you know how are people
going to read that and worrying about
those kind of things um I think the um
the solution to that is similar to a lot
of the other solutions that we've
offered and that is we need more clear
criteria about how you do mentorship how
you um how you give feedback so for
example on the work we're doing with
language um we've been evaluating lots
of performance evaluations and you know
the the language is overly creative I
mean people are writing things that are
just crazy in some of these reviews it's
it's just not good so what we've been
doing is working a little bit on
teaching people what kind of things you
say because if you're a manager and
you're told these are the kind of things
you talk about and your subordinate
knows these are the kind of things your
manager is going to say it's not going
to be misread it's going to be what the
company is suggesting that people do so
we have to provide tools to help people
that training in mentorship exactly and
the and and what's appropriate behavior
on the part of the mentor and what the
mentor own subc conscious feelings are
on during that inter yes interface yep
thank you sir yes we're doing a video
actually in our new voice and influence
series on having effective mentoring
relationships and we talk about the
roadblocks which include protective
hesitation on the part of the mentor to
give hard feedback and protective
defensiveness on the part of the mentee
to hear the hard feedback so we'll be
tackling that next
year exactly yes yes question over here
uh yes hi uh I'm Suzanne Butler I'm
class of
1964 50 years ago when I was an
undergraduate at Stanford there were
almost no women on the
faculty uh George Spindler was chairman
of the anthropology department and my
one experience with a woman faculty
member was his wife uh Lois Spindler and
she was a teaching assistant or
something along those lines the gender
ratio at the undergradu ual level I
think was five men to three women it
might have been five to two I thought
that was
great but that was
then my question now is how much
progress has Stanford made on hiring
women at uh full faculty and giving them
tenure yeah so uh so I I chair the
provos committee on faculty Equity so I
usually have these data handy so um I
should say the student body level we're
doing great okay I mean you know like
most universities really pretty close to
50/50 at The Faculty level at this point
in time amongst our um assistant
professors we're
27% female okay so we're a little over a
quarter when it comes to full professors
we're more between 21 and
22% um so about one and five so we're
not where we want to be we're not that's
not that's kind of on par with our peers
so it's not like you know Stanford's
having a unique problem here but we're
not we're not where we want to be with
that and I think there's a real
conservative effort um especially on
trying to hire women in the stem fields
and in the business school where women
are especially in low numbers um and and
importantly trying to H faculty of color
as well but we're we're not where we
want to be at this point yet with that
partly this is you
know yeah on there's okay on so on
tenure when we talk about tenuring
people from assistant to um you know to
associate professor there is not a
gender gap in who gets tenur and this is
this I think the university has given a
lot of thought to how it is that we are
evaluating people for 10 years so it's
not that gender never matters but
overall the pattern looks really pretty
good there so our question I think is
really our our challenge is hiring
people and getting them here um and then
I think I think we're doing okay on the
other
dimension I see we're almost out of time
maybe we could do one more question and
then I'm happy to uh answer a few
questions individually afterwards but um
so I think she was here first is that
sorry
your your comment on seeing the bias as
the mother of a uh tuba player female
tuba player five years ago when the
woman was uh hired for the
Philadelphia Symphony and there was all
the news articles on how woman had
finally landed the position none of them
mentioned that women had been winning
the position for years on the blind
auditions and then when they saw a woman
was chosen on the blind auditions they
redid them this ible not one news
article so I wrote in about the
statistics because I had them from a
tuba player with a master's degree is
there a place we should keep our eye to
um to check in with some of the
statistics because my awareness is
businesses all the time I'm with people
who do not
see acknowledge that there is a bias and
I have to have constant
statistics language to keep asking
having paraphrase asking for more
information can you give us something to
keep our eye
to yeah so this that you know the
statistics are going to be spread out
depending on the what the category is
but I but I want to just um I just want
to underline what you're doing as being
very important um that is you know now
it's pretty easy to Google and find
statistics on things when someone says
to you you know there are no women here
there are no women in the pipeline there
are no women that are eligible for this
that we should not take that as an
answer um that's almost always not the
case right so if I see you know major
Awards have just been given to people
and there's only one woman there out of
you know all 10 people that have been
nominated I write and say where are the
women and often I hear back well no one
nominated them or da D there's all these
excuses but there are women out there
and I think we have to help um point
that out to people so I would just
underscore that in those situations if
you hear there are no women dig a little
bit and find some for them because there
there are women there and we need to
help promote women all of us if we're
going to really Advance women's
leadership and I'll just end by saying
again I mean this is not just about
women this is about you know this is
about really driving the best Innovation
scientific discovery and solving the
biggest problems in our world we need to
have all people involved if the cure for
cancer is in you know the head of some
young African-American woman and we're
not listening to her we're all losing
out on that so we really this is
something that really affects us at a
societal level thank you all very
[Applause]
[Music]
much